it's important to note like in the day  and age we're in there's temptation  everything everywhere let me tell you if  you have a fine man or a fine woman  there are people waiting  waiting  patiently waiting so it's like you kind  of do like you know okay also like i'm  not saying women aren't but men are a  lot more like visual yeah women we're a  lot more internal emotional what are you  doing for me like like an exchange of  like goods almost like what are you  doing that kind of turns us off yeah the  things you can like almost give us in a  way but like men are like they'll see  something and they want it and they're  like oh sparkly like yeah like  well they're they're more they're more  visual yeah and also sex doesn't add  like like it's it's not as much to them  as it is  as a woman i'm not gonna get a dick pic  and be like  oh my god but he's a man like he's gonna  get a picture of a guy  and he's gonna be like i need to [ __ ]  this [ __ ] right now